pumpkin spice season is upon us so sorry
if you hate basic I don't drink coffee
so when I saw that Kourtney Kardashian
had released her pumpkin spice latte
recipe I was like you know what i'ma
make it pumpkin
magic happen wait I'm a messy pooch and
I'm real because if you're gonna try
something why not try the best and I
think Kourtney Kardashian will not let
me down I'm hoping that she will make me
a coffee convert and for anybody who
thinks that pumpkin spice is like not
real coffee because it's plumbing spice
I don't care if I'm counting it as
coffee for purposes of this video
[Music]
I'm going to Whole Foods Market to get
the ingredients let's go pumpkin pie
spice pumpkin puree organic maple syrup
then I'll extract almond milk pumpkin
puree has got to be here there are two
types of almond milk I'm not sure which
one to get so I'm gonna get both got it
be safe found organic maple syrup
boo-yeah check I'm get my spice all
right so I've got most everything I just
need vanilla extract that has to be
around here somewhere
vanilla extract where are you yeah I got
my baguette stuff and now I'm ready to
go see if I can make a pumpkin spice
latte I went shopping
Cortney posted this with photos of her
holding pumpkins so I feel like this is
probably an integral part of the pumpkin
spice latte making so let's do this
first I'm gonna measure out the
ingredients we got a half a teaspoon of
pumpkin pie spice it's already smelling
like full pumpkin puree requires a can't
open it should we became opener all
right
can opener I'm like way too old to not
know I just can't hold here like a
left-handed can opener something one
tablespoon of pumpkin puree a little
extra for good luck all right starting
to smell a little gross one teaspoon of
organic maple syrup I got both types of
almond milk because we're using maple
syrup I'm guessing on Sweden so that's
what we're gonna try first all right one
cup of almond milk
well and finally two teaspoons of
vanilla extract 1 teaspoon 2 teaspoon
and some spill when a tasty producer
does this this stuff doesn't happen but
I'm just being real I'm a messy and I'm
real Kourtney didn't include it on the
steps but if you spill something you
should clean it up heat the almond milk
in a small pot over low heat so that's
what this just I'm just gonna pour it in
they did get this fun spoon so I guess
maybe you stir no okay it doesn't say
stir
[Music]
maybe it's mad that I don't know how to
froth almond milk the instructions say
froth for about 15 seconds until gets
foamy I know what froth is but I don't
know what to froth is is there a device
I should be using is there frother that
froth
you know while this is heating up I'm
just gonna do a little quick [ __ ] how to
fry oh good somebody made a video thanks
Internet okay so Courtney says this
should take 8 minutes total so I don't I
feel like I'm already waited too long I
think it's getting close
alright so we're gonna get the 2 shots
of espresso which BuzzFeed's providing
espresso wait
what is the single expresso - isn't that
- single expresso
what would that mean I hate I hate
straight espresso straight coffee it
tastes like chocolate that somebody
burned and ruined oh my god wait magic
happened while we were gone it's like
boy
oh no it's wait it looks like it's um
Kurt curdling so should I try this again
I'm gonna get rid of this cuz it's
curdled almond milk apparently I'm
supposed to say three minutes
okay well that alright I did something
wrong I'm gonna assume it wasn't me was
the fact that I used unsweetened and
we're gonna try again with sweetened 1
cup we don't want the milk to be hot we
wanted to be warm so is this even on
well it says if you get a whisk and
whisk it vigorously by hand ok good they
definitely have a whisk I'm still doing
what Kourtney's telling me to do with
the heating in the pot on the low heat
but I'm also gonna add a vigorous whisk
I'm already seeing bubbles so I feel
already way better
I think the bubbles are a little soapy
and they need to be more micro so maybe
a little more vigorous
[Music]
amazing now we're on to step two and I'm
so proud we're gonna be combining the
two shots of espresso with the pumpkin
pie spice the puree the vanilla extract
and the maple syrup step three we add
these together in a blender
we're pouring into a mug and we're gonna
top with the frost milk we just garnish
with a little pumpkin pie spice
it says serve immediately so I'm going
to do it
I'm impressed holy it's actually like
good it takes the qualities I don't like
about coffee and it shuts them up and it
replaces them with pumpkin I'm proud I
think I made a great pumpkin spice latte
and I'm gonna see what other people
think of my masterpiece all right let's
go hey Sabrina can I offer you some of
my pumpkin spice latte I just hooked up
almost did you make it from scratch I
did isn't it this is a recipe from
Kourtney Kardashian yes she does
I make her avvocato pudding actually
Shea is she like a pumpkin expert cheers
Cheers
I don't know why I'm in here Ben tastes
like fall I like it the coffee taste
week is that it's almond milk that's
what I'm tasting that blandness oh okay
it's very watery and I don't like coffee
and I like it so I feel like coffee this
is why I was scared to tell people you
don't like coffee no you did a really
good job Sarah yeah you should be proud
of yourself thank you Kourtney it's
Kourtney Kardashian's pumpkin spice
latte it smells like eggnog it smells
like a gingerbread house but melted more
I should just taste it anything that's
delicious it tastes like lots of
cinnamon okay it's not bad if you steam
the milk yeah then it could become extra
frothy and I think that that's I should
have talked to earlier it just says like
to heat it in the directions and i sat
there heating it until it curdled and I
was like this is wrong I have a lot of
frothing issues it's a frog I feel like
my water is just as froth this I guess
that's something I can improve on all
you've done is made coffee with almond
milk instead of milk okay you're making
it sound like I didn't do a lot and try
really hard which I did so alright Thank
You Christian
alright I'm gonna enjoy my spoils
yes it's what I've been working on all
day I have another one down there
[Music]
do you know what's the span of caregiver
month nobody you got four more Latino
content right here
[Music]